well let's uh let's jump into this story
we have this from the post millennial
breaking transgender Nashville school
shooter had detailed Manifesto map of
Christian School police confirm Hale was
killed after an encounter with officers
on the second floor just four minutes
into the shooting so I'll give you a
quick timeline of the news as it's
breaking for us in The Newsroom and uh
we were actually hanging out with Libby
Emmons earlier too and we we knew that
the story had had broken and there was
some speculation as to who the shooter
was who committed this tragedy let me
give you the quick details on what
happened so you can understand police
said during a Monday press conference at
the person who killed six including
three children at the Covenant Christian
school in Nashville was a former student
of the academy Audrey Hale who
identified as transgender and had left a
detailed Manifesto with plans on how to
conduct the attack at the school Hale
entered the building by shooting through
a door on the side police said once
inside Hale reporter began firing at
anyone in sight among the victims were
three nine-year-old children Evelyn
decos Hallie Haley Scruggs and William
Kinney as well as custodian Mike Hill
substitute teacher Cynthia Peak and
school head Catherine Kuntz Metropolitan
Police arrived quickly and Hale was
killed after an encounter with officers
in the second floor just four minutes
into the shooting officers found that
Hale was equipped with at least two
assault rifles in a handgun and a search
of the family home in Nashville revealed
detailed maps and a Manifesto of the
attack first thing I want to say is I
believe the post-millennial is incorrect
so I'll make sure to call up Libby and
complain Roberto wakerell Cruz I do not
believe they ever said this individual
had any assault rifles for those that
think I'm being a bit pedantic there is
a legal and legitimate difference
between a standard rifle like an AR-15
and an assault rifle which is typically
a select fire rifle I don't think this
person was able to get their hands on on
a full auto machine you know a full auto
rifle to go in and start I think this
was a standard rifle I think distinction
is important considering from this we're
getting a lot of calls for gun control
so we're hanging out earlier when when
the you know the news breaks we don't
know exactly what's going on when rumors
starts circulating about Aubrey Hale as
the the perpetrator and images of a
trans man and a profile with he him
pronouns the media had to report it been
reporting this as a female who did it
which caught me by surprise because
people were shocked to hear that it was
a woman who was doing this turns out it
was a trans man
and we eventually did get a confirmation
at Carroll k-a-r-o-l on Twitter airtight
Source broke the news this in fact was
the person Andy no then did some digging
corroborating and yes it is now
officially confirmed that this
individual is the person who did it now
according to the police they were asked
by press did the identity of the
individual play a role in the motivation
and they said
there is a theory that is the case they
have a Manifesto
preparing explaining for uh what they
did and why they did it so for now it
would seem that the individual who did
it this is this is what we have
confirmed the individual who perpetrated
this attack attack is a biological
female 28 year old Aubry Hale and a
transgender man the meaning female to
male using him pronouns and it is
presumed for the time being based on
reasons of a Manifesto the police
believe they have a theory that the
transgender identity played a role in
the attack uh in the attack so I'm I'm
assuming from that this has something to
do with a trans person feeling like
they're under attack or assault we've
seen numerous posters which we'll get
into in a bit about a trans day of
Vengeance about calls to Arms posters
online saying get your weapons ready and
Benny Johnson posted three other mass
shootings carried out by transgender
individuals so perhaps this is related
to this uh um this call for Venge agents
and and a call to Arms I don't know I
think it's more related to woke left
ideology but uh it's hard to know for
sure until the police come out and we
actually get to see what this Manifesto
is if we do get to see it I don't know
yeah so I'm curious what you guys think
Kenneth Owens made an interesting point
about 40 minutes ago on Twitter that
even if this Manifesto comes out we have
to trust that it's real like it's the
intelligence Community putting out data
we don't know if it's real they could
put out a fake Manifesto there might not
even be a Manifesto I hate to be like
question everything but do not fall for
the bait every single time because you
want bait make sure you have a clear
head about it and part of this is like
thank God it wasn't someone going and
executing trans people like we've had
cool we've kept cool heads about
ourselves as Americans for the most part
what in this crazy new time where people
are taking all these experimental
Pharmaceuticals to take testosterone on
their nine and get their boobs cut off
at 15 like thank God it wasn't somebody
attacking transgender people as horrific
as it is you don't stop your enemy when
they're making a mistake in the culture
War if these people are drugging them
themselves up and committing mass
shootings it's on them well I I think
one of the things we have to be worried
about I'm not so sure here's what I
think we talked about a little bit
before the show
there's there's there's not one kind of
trans person there are gender dysphoric
individuals and they experience gender
dysphoria like people might just uh
experience body dysmorphia but then
there are people who are depressed or
autistic and they they get they end up
getting put on antidepressants and you
know a variety of other drugs and so I
think when you take someone who is
depressed doesn't understand why they
are and rush to giving them
antidepressants and hormones and Other
Drugs I think the issue is mental health
and then what ends up happening is
because there is
I think because of popular culture in
the massive social acceptance of
transgender individuals there's a
conflation an overlap with those who are
seeking social validation and then
becoming trans we've talked about this
with with Dylan Mulvaney Dylan mulvania
my opinion is not trans is not gender
dysphoric but is seeking social
validation and getting it and so I think
what we might be seeing with people like
this is they're depressed they don't
know why they're depressed they're told
because of what's in popular culture
maybe it's it's this maybe you're trans
and then they end up getting hormones
which I mean testosterone makes anybody
more aggressive even biological males
they get antidepressants now they've got
a cocktail of drugs in their mind
they've already been suffering suffering
mental health issues then you give a
bunch of testosterone
you're going to end up with stories like
this and it's and it's tragic I don't
I'm not going to pretend to have the
answers man you were wise to start off
by saying look at first instance all we
know is that there was a tragedy
innocent lives lost that's what we know
but at a certain point there are enough
political elements that we have to say
is this I hate crime is this yes it is
does it have the markings and
characteristics of terrorism and what is
Terrorism it's violence to intimidate
for a certain political goal and what
you're talking about a day of Vengeance
there's a larger ideology of aggression
to deal with opponents of transgenderism
the language the vile language directed
at JK Rowling at at um there was a
popular Republic yeah she was just in
New Zealand basically drummed out of the
place Posey Parker Posey Parker Parker
Posey's an actress wait wait uh Park
Posey Parker how is he possible it's
Kelly
she's been on the show and here's the
thing it's like the same word this this
is the well
let me Slow Down based on what the
police have said about a Manifesto and
the targeting of a school I believe it
is beyond a reasonable doubt now timing
Friday is trans visibility day
international well and they've been
they've been calling with social media
posts for a day of Vengeance
now here's here's the thing
we need to stop the violence we need we
need to tone all of this down the issue
is it is the left
oh so you've got people out in the
middle of nowhere who are sovereign
citizens there's this guy
as I was going to mention a moment ago
he's uh I think he he's a researcher for
like the Anti-Defamation League or
something like that and I followed him
for a long time because you know I don't
mind you know I'll see what he has to
say when he's reporting on this stuff
typically it's like right-wing groups
and he recently argued that the Jews in
Germany
he he was effectively arguing they
should not have had guns because it
wouldn't have mattered anyway
people were people were uh it was there
was a I think it was Michigan GOP posted
that if you know that Nazi Germany had
been
Michigan jupi posted that Nazi Germany
took away the guns from Jewish people
and that if they had them they would
have been able to fight back
this guy
starts tweeting about how there weren't
enough Jews anyway so stop acting like
they could have prevented anything and
it's a crazy argument to make I don't
care if it's one versus a hundred if if
a Jewish person is facing down 100 Nazis
give like let them defend themselves
please yeah so this mentality among
among these people who supposedly oppose
hate is what that they were supposed to
submit and just roll over and I it is it
is it is absolutely absurd this is the
gun control argument and so you have
here three nine-year-old children
and three faculty members a janitor I
mean what did he do to anybody who's
nothing to do with any of this he's just
cleaning and this person breaks in I
believe it is beyond a reasonable doubt
that this is an act of terrorism it is a
hate crime whatever you want to call it
I don't like hate crimes I don't like
the structure of what they are a crime's
a crime you should somebody shoot
somebody trying to determine motivation
is a difficult thing we know and if it
is then then it's Terror
this is what we're seeing right now in
this country we are seeing far left
extremists in Georgia commit acts of
terrorism burning down houses setting
fire to this this police uh facility
shooting at cops
we're seeing over the past several years
with the summer of love just just
endless it's endless
but you get one right wing riot at the
Capitol
and then all of a sudden that that that
that that is the news and nothing else
matters it's because the corporate press
is covering up for what is clearly a
problem that needs to be addressed and
it's mental health yeah I think we've
been screaming that non-stop every time
we see one of these mass shootings I
think every time there's Pharmaceuticals
involved school shootings I'm talking
about I could be wrong because it's
obfuscated probably by Insight because
the people that sponsored the news are
probably Pfizer and moderna and these
crazy corporations that are making the
drugs that the kids are taking that
they're then they're losing their minds
there's definitely mental health always
I mean I I find myself contrasting
today's you know tragedy with Vivaldi
right like the student who is the
teenager who was involved in that was
you know reportedly socially withdrawn
he had anxiety had depression uh and
then the other part that I can't stop
thinking about is the fact that law
enforcement waited to enter the building
like I know there's a lot of criticism
of law enforcement in today's scenario
and many of much of his Justified but
thank goodness law enforcement entered
the building here and prevented did an
even bigger tragedy right six people
dying is too many on the other hand at
least they entered the building I think
that our country has conflated uh what
we should be doing with how we PR how
we're afraid of being perceived right
the cops are afraid of what's going on
in the building so they don't enter in
Texas but here they enter because we
know that they made a mistake when we
look at mental health we're afraid of
seeming uh bigoted or closed-minded and
so we say yeah identify however you want
to identify but really we know that we
are doing a disservice to people who are
genuinely confused and in distress by
letting them operate in a gen on a
gender spectrum that is ultimately
furthering their confusion and and
suffering yeah believe what you like if
you want to think you're a carrot okay
but if you start taking psychotropics
dude you gotta watch out well also if
you think you're a carrot I'm not gonna
tell you you're a carrot right I want to
help you and I don't want you to be in
distress but I'm not going to let you
continue to operate in a way that just
completely distresses you further well
you're an anti-carat bigot obviously I I
just but there's a combination of things
here you have I mean teenagers young
people
hormones emotions fitting in in this
crazy world the stress of social media
it's tough to be a young person add in
uh the ideological component
transgenderism I believe is very
ideological and then put in the meds and
that is and you know what I I don't talk
a lot about MK Ultra or other psycho uh
drug oriented experiments done by
authorities going back frankly a lot of
that stuff started
the Nazis when they had uh all this
massive Humanity in the death camps the
Nazis did experiments on on humans
without their permission obviously in
Auschwitz and other places Dr Joseph
Mengele they called him the angel of
death he did experiments on twins he did
experiments on hypothermia he did all
these atrocious experiments after the
second World War
some of those experiments were picked up
by America by the CIA and they they
continued in this and you would say you
could say it continues to this day in
places like Wuhan to do biological
experiments atrocious things but now
it's not just a handful of people now
it's gone broad it's gone public and I
think that of course the real victims
here are the shooting victims but the
perpetrator was revved up and weaponized
and ideologically directed if this
Manifesto is what I fear it is well I
think it's uh I think it's
probably the case that this was a
response to Tennessee Banning these
these surgeries
and I believe that they're all I don't
want to say too much more than that look
they're going to be passing this law of
course the daily wire played a large
role in advocating for this and we
recently had Michael Knowles say that we
need to eradicate transgenderism
referring specifically in the context of
a speech to the ideology of gender
ideology but of course that was taken by
political opponents and turned into
arguments that he was calling for
genocide the interesting thing is
even if Michael Knowles simply said that
it turns out to have been the other side
that went and targeted children in
school which is just needless it serves
nope nope no purpose other than to hurt
your own political cause this is what
I've been warning about man we need
people to to uh chill out
but I feel like
the internet is hyper radicalizing
people every single day and so I want to
make sure we stress this point that's
why you know people will like to say
examples of Milton's Fun Center look
I don't think this is about
transgender we gotta we gotta make sure
we separate woke from trans because
we've had trans people on the show who
are clearly not woke clearly not an
opposite outright you have gaze against
groomers and then you have their sister
organization trans against groomers but
there are people who are this is what I
keep saying I'll put it this way that
woke does not refer to this leftist
Marxist theory
that woke is more about the cult-like
adherence to left tribal social
Orthodoxy their support for Ukraine has
nothing to do with Karl Marx I mean like
why why do they fly the flag that makes
no sense but there's a strong
correlation between those who do and
what we would refer to as woke what
we're seeing with these people I believe
is they're going on the internet they're
seeking social validation they are
finding it in these rules and policies
and then pushing themselves further and
further into that hyper-radicalized
social validation the example that often
uses when Trump started running for uh
for office you know now now what man
this is eight years ago
they wrote an article saying Trump is
racist they get a million views if they
write the same article twice they don't
get a million views the second time so
they have to say Trump is even more
racist than they have to say Trump is
the most racist then they have to say
Trump is almost as bad as Hitler then
Trump is as bad as Hitler and then
finally Trump is worse than because if
you don't give people more the same
story won't trigger that dopamine hit
this is what's happening to people
online they're posting something I mean
you you this is we talked about this
again with Dylan Mulvaney if you if you
look at Dylan Mulvaney's Tick Tock
account and go all the way to the
beginning it's animal videos
animal videos then Broadway videos then
non-binary then trans then time for
surgery and and the days of girlhood
like clearly what you see is p and you
can do this for almost any YouTuber look
at Mr Beast you see their early content
and then eventually they figured out
what got them social validation and
traffic and then they start adhering to
it and escalating more and more and more
that's why I want to say there's a
difference between trans people and woke
ideology this this attack comes from the
woke cult it is an element of the left
things that Democrats support and I
assure you they're going to be and there
are trans people clearly want nothing to
do with this and would would be
absolutely against this and the woke
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time